Mercury.
It's a really beautiful substance.
It's the only metal that's a liquid at room
temperature and pressure.
It doesn't become a solid until it goes below
-38 degrees Celsius.
In its liquid state the atoms have enough
thermal energy to overcome the rigid metallic
bonds
that confine most metals to solid structures
at room temperature.
Because of this, the atoms haev enough energy
to jiggle about and flow past one another.
And it's the third law of thermodynamics
which links the temperature to the level of
entropy in a system.
So, as the temperature of a system reaches
absolute zero,
the level of entropy reaches its lowest possible
value.
When the mercury atoms in the liquid have
enough thermal energy
they can break free from the surface in the
form of a vapour.
This vapour has a higher entropy state, meaning
there are more ways in which the atoms can
arrange themselves in the space around them.
The less energy there is in a substance, the
more ordered the atoms are within it.
This is why when you cool the liquid it turns
into a solid.
So if we use liquid nitrogen to take the temperature
of the mercury down below its freezing point
at -39 degrees,
we know that we will also be reducing its
entropy.
Which means we'll be able to play around with
it as a solid.
Say mould it into something like....
a hammer!
At this point mercury becomes more like many
of the solids you may be familiar with at
room temperature.
It's much more rigid and less malleable.
It forms a solid metal in which all the atoms
are ordered in a regular crystalline structure.
Which means the atoms arrange themselves in
a repeating pattern throughout the solid.
But although the atoms are arranged in this
solid crystalline structure,
they're not completely motionless.
A more precise phrasing of the third law would
state:
'the entropy of a perfect crystal at absolute
zero is exactly equal to zero.'
So we'd have to have a perfectly arranged
crystal and remove absolutely all the thermal
energy to reduce the entropy to zero.
The problem is that the concept of absolute
zero is a theoretical one.
It's just not possible to completely remove
all the thermal energy from within a substance.
So it might seem strange to have absolute
zero in our laws of thermodynamics,
given that it's a theoretical temperature,
but it provides us with an absolute scale
with which we can link temperature and entropy.
This in turn allows us to understand how temperature
influences the behaviours of systems and materials
in the world around us,
which is pretty important when we study the
climate, or design anything from
spacecraft to microwaves to... mercury hammers.
(It fell down!)
(Ooh!)
(Were we filming?)
(Yeah.
It's like the Terminator...)